well happy Monday and happy Halloween
at least for Miley Cyrus and Cody
Simpson who just shared the most
terrifying video of themselves on Cody's
Instagram story and let's just play that
last part one more time to make sure you
really saw their tongues not gonna lie
it kind of reminds me of this so it's
unclear if Cody and Miley are just
having fun playing with Instagram
filters or also big fans of Joker I mean
you kind of hear the Joker laugh in the
background but what is clear things
between them seem to be getting more
serious by the day last week Cody was
visiting Miley in the hospital you can't
take this guy anywhere nope you can't
take this day anyway rip some Elvis in
Vigo oh and he wrote a song about her
[Music]
now we still don't know just how serious
things are but we do know they go way
back this was in 2014 my she's
definitely like a very like at heart a
very very sweet normal like go for
Nashville like and we were spending on
our ranch in Nashville and she's just
like I'm just like a lot of people say
these things like that you know she's
just like the coolest Jake earlier this
month the stores told et Miley and Cody
have hooked up in the past but have no
plans to start dating each other
exclusively and our source adds that
Miley wants to be open and honest and
hook up with whomever she pleases and
right now Cody is that person alright
guys that's it for today for all the
latest on Miley and Cody and their
blossoming romance stick with all things
et until next time I'm Katie Krauss and
bye for now
[Music]
you